you're watching screen junkie central
today's episode is brought to you by
t-mobile
the uncarrier what's going on everybody
dan merrill here at comic-con 2016 we
are outside hallways for the warner
brothers panel just let out and of
course the big news that job all things
DC we got our first trailer for Wonder
Woman we got our first look at the
Justice League we got a new trailer for
Suicide Squad plus we got to look at
Kong Skull Island so much we're going to
talk to some of the fans here comic-con
some of our friends that were in Hall H
and bring you the latest of what we just
saw let's check it out you know this man
he's a friend of ours from Collider
Frosty's he's rocking a comic-con day 3
voice exactly I've completely lost it
but I'm trying the big news of course we
got our first look at extended look at
the Wonder Woman movie they dropped the
trailer what you think of the first look
at Wonder Woman I think the Wonder Woman
footage and I'm sure you did the same it
looks fantastic
it's an extremely well cut trailer it
looks nothing like the superhero movies
that that have been released thus far by
DC and Marvel alright guys I'm here with
Roth cornet our newest green junkie
working with us in a mystery capacity
Roth you were in Hall H what do you
think it's interesting because there had
been a part of me that wondered how is
this all going to work together this
mythology in world war 1 which if you're
talking about something that would turn
off Wonder Woman from engaging with man
it would be World War 1 it was such a
brutal war but actually it worked
together seamlessly that sword in the
midst of the gunplay was a kind of
glorious just the shield stopping that
hail of fire and bullets right
absolutely and I love the the that shot
where she's walking to the party she's
in a beautiful dress and it cuts to the
back and she's got the sword behind her
moment having about it her moments and
dawn of Justice don't do her justice
what we saw in that trailer was more
amazing than anything I've ever seen in
my life I didn't love the trailer start
to finish but the action sequences that
patty Jenkins and company put together
what
pastic it is going to be something
special and we have less than a year
until you get to check it out sir what's
your name hal Rudnick and were you in
haulage to see any of the footage today
no I wasn't okay that thank you then
that's I'm so excited I've been waiting
for a Wonder Woman movie for a while and
to finally have it and I think they
picked the perfect actress to play it
that was really great I mean she was a
bad bad woman she it's gonna be awesome
plus with Chris Pine what's not to love
there I think I was most excited to see
the tease of Justice League right
because they're still in production but
it actually gave us a pretty good feel
of some of these relationships Aquaman
and Batman Bruce Wayne going at it a
scene that we we'd seen from journalists
that had visited the set that it scene
it looked like they premiered it here at
Comic Con that the centerpiece of course
Bruce Wayne recruiting the flash it
played well what did you think you know
how did it cut together uh when I was on
set they showed us that seen the full
seat of a flash coming back to his
apartment
Bruce recruiting him and we saw a scene
on the rooftop of the Gotham police
station what we didn't see on set and
they showed today was that Aquaman stuff
Bruce trying to recruit Aquaman these
really Zack Snyder asked shots of
Aquaman over the water and the water
splashing making him look like a badass
I think the footage for Justice League
looks awesome and the thing that they're
selling in this and everyone can see
online is the difference in tone coolest
part was watching Ben Affleck his Batman
on the recruiting trail like he's a
college basketball coach he's trying to
get Aquaman to join the league he's
trying to get the flash
he's maybe throws
at the glasses it down slash me Isis
who's talking to him it was a really
neat suit and it gives me a lot of hope
for justice Bruce Wayne recruiting
Aquaman what you think of that I kind of
like there's a little bit of conflict
you know not everyone's just signing up
and ready to go that there's a little
bit of a pushback you know it seems like
Aquaman kind of does his own thing and
that was really exciting to see it's not
just everyone's just going to show up
and there's going to be a battle and
it's going to be like a animated TV show
it's going to actually have a storyline
there's gonna be some struggle and some
team-building and that's that's
something to look forward to
of course they brought Henry Cavill out
to join the Justice League that was no
surprise that he will be I guess this is
our first official confirmation that
Superman will be shocked that Superman
is gonna be in Justice League that is
just shocking I know a shocking turn of
events and I know this is gonna be
controversial got to say I liked Ezra
Miller's the flash would you think I did
and I'm not saying this in a bad way it
was very similar comparison to the scene
between Peter Parker and Tony Stark and
Civil War something else they teach this
last year with the graphic they teach
that this year with the graphic still no
news Green Lantern Corps stills in the
list from one of others as part of the
DC EU but no news whatsoever no news
whatsoever but I think that they just
put that in there to be like yeah yeah
this is still happening this is still
we're still working on this but let's
pay attention right now I mean obviously
they want to put the focus on Suicide
Squad because that's what's coming out
next they want to get that message back
Justice League is going to be awesome
they want that message out there that's
why they showed the teaser and they
wanted people to be hyped about war
Wonder Woman other than the DC
properties anything else stand out front
for you from the WB presentation
anything that maybe surprised you a
little bit yeah I loved the Lego Batman
they did a panel for Lego Batman and it
started with like them actually having
Lego Batman pretend to be in Hall H so
it's animated like Lego Batman was
coming with Joker and a Lego Conan
O'Brien I don't know if they're gonna
release that footage but that was
fantastic and original and it shows the
creativity of those people making those
films hey we didn't even get to mention
Kong Skull Island looked fantastic I
actually I think that that gave me the
biggest chill because I'm a big sort of
big monster fan my favorite trailer I
with Skull Island just because its first
footage that we've seen from the film
and obviously it felt like puddles now
it felt like gritty 70s kind of warmly
in a way it looked but then you have
this larger-than-life
check-cashing least really so for me
that was a highlight okay guys that's
everything here from the Warner Brothers
panel but we're not done yet we're going
to be back in Hall H later today for the
Marvel panel and we're going to be
talking to fans we're going to be
talking to our friends everyone in the
know what are we going to find out about
the world of Marvel Comics we'll find
out later today thank you for watching
I'll wrap up a DC and Warner Brothers
I'm not how Rudnick I am Dan Morrell bye
bye thanks again to sponsor t-mobile
with double the LTE coverage get your
screen junkies fix and more places to
watch our preview show
click to the left and to view everything
else from screen junkie central click to
the right